you want to prove the point about the
border you dress like osama bin laden i
don't know if you can pull this up
you dress like osama bin laden and you
cross the border to prove a point
to say here's how bad the border is if
you can go to images and david if we can
show this
this is james o'keefe okay right there
to the right if he can show that
another time i think you went in
uh uh acting like you're a pimp with a
prostitute right who was that that you
were trying to expose that was that was
a group called acorn and you expose them
and you this is an organ organization
that had been around since 1971 500 000
something correct you know members that
they had and right afterwards six months
later you you pretty much shut down the
organization at the time when you did it
was oh seven which is 15 years ago you
were what 23 years old 24 years old you
bet yeah so so this is what i mean by
like these strategies and tactics you
got to have a creative mind to say i'm
gonna play your game against you yeah
but and i think i
i think i answered that in so far as
that we do whatever we need to do to get
the information and and for the acorn
story that i could we could spend 30
minutes talk about that story but in a
minute it was it was this young woman
who messaged me on facebook like i get
most of these tips these days from the
citizens and she said what if you went
in there as a prostitute and this was a
this is a government you're telling her
she's telling me she's giving me this
idea on a facebook message in 2009
and we get our tips and ideas and at the
time i was i was nothing i had no money
i had no organization i was just a
filmmaker with these ideas and she had
seen what i did with planned parenthood
she said why don't you go in there as a
prostitute and we're having this i've
never met this woman before we're just
talking over facebook i said well there
probably should be a pimp and what
occurred to me is how brilliant it was
because this is an organization that was
doing illegal things squatting
foreclosed homes they were they were
accused of doing corrupt acts so if you
went in there and said you were a
criminal and you had
a deviant business
you would you would get a reaction now i
thought that they would
i assumed i had my hypotheses was that
they would perhaps tell us to evade the
authorities or something something
mildly you know fraudulent when i went
in there in baltimore and with my hidden
camera embedded in my satin tie with
with hannah was dressed like a she was
from miami she was from miami a 20 year
old dressed like a she had stilettos and
a sarong and a
leather halter top they told me how to
disguise the underage hookers his
dependence on the tax returns they
brought in the accountant this was like
this was like something out of a you
know an sll skit um but they actually
wanted to help us evade the law
and and it it got quite serious it got
quite serious very fast i mean those
videos
prompted congress to defund acorn
democratically controlled congress so it
wasn't me
that destroyed or defunded acorn it was
the united states congress there we are
there's hannah that's what she looked
like she went in there now i did not
wear that fur coat in every office uh
but she wore that in baltimore by the
way prostitutes prostitutes do not look
like that in baltimore but these workers
wanted to help us
and we did this in uh baltimore d.c new
york
san bernadino los angeles every office
helped us but won
now i got to tell you you're sitting
here right across the room you don't
look like a pimp it'd be very hard for
you to pass as a pimp but that picture
right there you got very close to
looking like a pimp that's true
a low budget one but he does look like
one thing for sure
his pimp hand is strong regardless well
it was just it was so low budget uh
people at the time this was a massive
story i don't know if people remember it
but it was it was big
um and the late andrew breitbart
described it like taking the penthouse
to the glass elevator all the way to the
top with with the what we did and
i might i did not have any money so that
that fur coat was my grandmother's coat
the hat was my grandfather's hat hannah
accoutred herself
and we drove around in my old my old
jalopy grand marquis and
we just did it i mean we just two kids
from the cast of high school musical
three so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye
[Music]